Speaker 1: Do you remember that quaint era in
American politics in 2008 where we thought Sarah
Palin is the craziest that anyone involved in
politics will be? Sarah Palin is the wackiest.
Sarah Palin is the most cartoonish and ignorant
and unqualified. We're never going to see anything
below Sarah Palin. And of course, we were very
wrong. And then came Trump and Trumpism and a bevy
of candidates worse than Sarah Palin. But Sarah
Palin has gotten even worse over the last couple
of decades. Sarah Palin is now running for
member of Congress in Alaska. She was invited
to speak both before Trump at the Trump rally
in Anchorage and during. And it was really,
really weird. Sarah Palin called on Alaskan
chicks to show people what makes them women. Now.
If you've looked at, you know, maybe
certain medical journals lately,
the question of showing what makes you a woman
is an interesting thing to demand women do. But
that's what Sarah Palin did. Check it out.
Speaker 3: To our leaders not being able
to tell us they don't know what a woman is.
Hey, are you Alaskan chicks out there?
Unidentified: Maybe you can show. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Show everybody how you
know that you're a woman. A very,
very strange request. Then Sarah Palin was
invited up during Trump's speech to speak
almost completely incoherent. Now, we've talked
before. Sometimes Sarah Palin really struggles
to use words and then to combine them and to try
to communicate things of meaning. This is maybe
the worst I've ever seen her. A lot of people.
Speaker 3: Ask me, how did you know that? You know
President Trump, that Donald J. Trump was going to
be the best president that we'd ever had. How did
how did you think to do get out there and endorse
him early when, gosh, you know, there was a lot of
party pressure on me and others to endorse, you
know, established candidates and all that. And
I knew well, personally speaking for years.
Speaker 1: Even Trump is confused by this
and he'll accept any praise. But this,
he's like, What is she talking about?
Speaker 3: Donald Trump watched what the
fake media, the fake news, the lamestream
media put my kids through.
Unidentified: Remember that.
The things that you guys.
Speaker 3: Did to my kids.
Speaker 1: By the way, the pointing to the back.
Nobody's covering these rallies. It's basically
Newsmax, right side broadcasting. And if I don't
have anything better going on, I'll cover their
coverage. There's nothing whatever they think
of as the fake news media. There's none of it
there. Nobody's even talking about these things.
Speaker 3: TRUMP He would write me a note and he
would say, Hang in there. The people who know
you, they love you. They know the truth about
your family sitting right over there.
Unidentified: God bless. Drag by
and I. If this man cared about family.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Trump really a deeply
spiritual and also really a family man. At another
point, Sarah Palin suggested that the right not
retreat but rather reload, which is really a great
message when we're plagued by mass shootings.
Speaker 3: Oh, my dad. No, he was all
about, you know, you stiffen your spine,
you use what they throw at you as fuel.
Let it strengthen and fortify you and you
fight for what is right. Well, my dad's
words exactly were don't retreat, reload.
Speaker 1: Now, that's a message the crowd
can get behind. Thinly veiled allusions to
violence at a time during we are with which
we are plagued by mass shootings. A couple
other real quick ones. In this segment,
Sarah Palin discusses Donald Trump's balls.
Speaker 3: And all of them
because I knew them all.
He was the only one who had the balls to take.
Unidentified: On the fake media. Fake it
to take on.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
CLINTON And lastly, Sarah Palin during her speech
using the term plandemic, which of course, is
a buzzword for the utter bottom
feeding, worst of the worst COVID
conspiracy theorists.
Speaker 3: This is
this is life changing. What's coming up here
in the midterms, the change that are needed.
And it's no longer Democrat versus Republican.
This is all about control versus freedom. It's.
It's good versus evil.
Unidentified: It is a
spiritual battle.
Speaker 3:
They use the pandemic as an example in order to
achieve a goal of controlling you, the plandemic.
Speaker 1: So this now is welcomed by what has
become the mainstream of the Republican Party,
Trumpism and later in the show, or
maybe tomorrow, if I don't get to it,
we are going to take a deep look at polling
data. Is Trumpism currently dominant in the
Republican Party? It's an important question.
And thinking about these midterms in about 2024.
We're going to take a quick break. All of these
clips, if you were just listening today and you
have a sort of morbid, sick curiosity as to
what it looked like, we will have these clips
on our Instagram at David Pakman show. And
then after the break, we'll look at a couple
of interviews with rally goers. And I will warn
you, it's just as bad or worse than Sarah Palin